c'est l'une des conséquences du
confinement les messes à l'église sont
interdites pour compenser certains
catholiques se tourner vers la
télévision
cette alternative ne date pas d'hier la
première fois qu'une équipe de
télévision a filmé une messe
c'était à notre dame de paris pour la
messe de noël 1948
aujourd'hui grâce à internet et la
télévision
retransmettre une messe en direct et
banale mais à l'époque l'événement est
inédit c'est une première mondiale
la télévision dans n'est qu'à ses débuts
et seules quelques centaines de français
en sont équipés cette messe en direct
c'est donc un défi humain et technique
retransmis par la rdf télévision
française le mystère de la naissance du
christ est célébrée par son éminence le
cardinal suhard archevêque de paris
derrière cet exploit un homme raymond
pichard à la fois pionnier de la
télévision est prêtre dominicain c'est
l'un des premiers à avoir flairé le
potentiel de la petite lucarne pour la
communauté catholique
sur ces images c'est lui qui s'occupe de
traduire la messe réciter ans l'attend
cette première est un succès alors
l'expérience est renouvelée très
rapidement avril 1949 la messe de pâques
et retransmise à la télévision depuis
l'église des carmes à paris et là encore
le dispositif technique est
impressionnant
cam qui tombe le long de la façade des
carmes relie les caméras aux cars de
reportage ingénieurs et metteur en scène
reçoivent et choisissent les images
l'émission est dirigée vers les antennes
des studios et de là vers la tour eiffel
ces retransmissions sont des succès et
ont trouvé leur public
du coup dès octobre 49 la messe
dominicale et retransmise chaque
dimanche sur la rtf à l'origine du
programme encore le père raymond pichard
ici la messe est célébrée à l'abbaye de
royaumont dans le val d'oise
en 1957 la messe que vous allez entendre
et une messe polyphonique été composée
par le chef de choeur de la chorale la
faluche la circonstance de la tête
d'aujourd'hui d'abord son nom l'émission
est baptisé le jour du seigneur en 1954
aujourd'hui elle est toujours diffusée à
la télévision française c'est la plus
ancienne encore en activité pendant le
premier confinement elle a battu des
records d'audience jusqu'à 2,4 millions
de téléspectateurs le 14 avril 2020 pour
la messe de pâques
[Musique]